you go on to say when we first started
training using the helicopters the plan
called for captain dan to be the first
man off and for me to be the second now
i had watched enough war movies to know
that the first men off any vehicle get
killed for a couple of weeks we trained
this way i thought oh we already
gonna make it off the chopper i can now
admit that every time i stepped up
stepped off the chopper the thought went
through my mind of getting zapped before
my foot even hit the ground
then after a few rehearsals the plan
changed to where captain dan and i were
the last two off the chopper all of a
sudden i thought damn now that i'm the
last guy off the bad guys will have
their sights locked on i will get nailed
for sure eventually i had to admit that
if the good lord wants me he doesn't
care from the first the last or the
middle my maker is going to bring me
home when it's my time
that's uh some good young paranoia right
either way you're getting shot that's
right
you say life lesson five and this is an
important one be prepared for death
don't worry about it you can't
completely control it
make sure that the day you meet your
maker is not the first time you've been
introduced
if you are prepared at all times you're
free to live life fearless and that was
your attitude eventually you had to say
you know what whether i'm first whether
i'm last if it's my time it's my time i
can only control so much
and you know
that point was really driven home last
week when my wife passed away that
you know
[Music]
she she
was prepared to meet her maker i know
that and uh she's in a better place
today because of that so
it holds true in my mind
so
um well i mean it's it's a testament
when you can say that
you know that your wife who lived a
amazing life
and and
she passed away
and you know we were talking before
we we started that you said well we're
gonna come out here anyways we're gonna
record this thing because she would want
me to carry on with the mission yep
exactly
um
yeah it's a it's a it's an important
part of the book you know and
i think that i think that happens with
young guys going into combat
you have to get to a point where you say
man you know what
this could
i could die tonight yeah but you could
do that walking across a road you could
do that walking across the road and you
you can only control the things you
control you can train hard
you can prepare you can study the plan
you can mitigate the risk but there's
some risk you're not gonna be able to
mitigate right
and if you concentrate on those things
it's going to drive you crazy that's
going to say it takes away from
everything else yeah
exactly
um
you talk more about some of the training
that you did again you got to buy the
book to get all the details
you talk about uh some of the friday
night fights which was they would bring
like a band and and
boos and women and they had like a bar
set up
and so you do that on friday nights and
again it's crazy to think that you guys
still didn't know where you were going
you guys had no idea where you're going
you thought you might be going to cuba
i think there was somewhere else you
thought you might be going there were
planes hijacked on tarmacs around the
world that we thought we might be going
in to
rescue you know people on hijacked
planes so you have no idea what you're
doing no which
and everybody you know it was we didn't
know we just knew we were going to do
some type of rescue
and we trained
for it
and did you know that it was real
so no okay because i know sometimes we
would get spun up in such a way where
they'd be like hey we've got a mission
and we think actually this the very
first deployment i went on
we got recalled we had little beepers
and i was in guam and we had beepers and
they said hey if this thing shows up
9-1-1 you know you got
20 minutes to get to base because
something's going on
so we get there and i'm i'm
well i'm i guess i'm 19 or 20 at this
point
maybe i'm 20 or 21 but anyways i'm young
and very dumb
and i also think that i'm you know i
think i'm going to vietnam you know i
think i'm i think i'm going to be like
the combination of james bond and rambo
and everybody else
so we show up in guam on deployment my
paseo platoon
it's 1992.
or 1993 anyways
but i think there's just you know this
is it we're going to war
so we go out we get all we go out the
range we get all of our weapons dialed
in and i'm just
totally ready
and then
um
i'm doing something and i get that the
911 on my pager and um oh there you go
here it is it's on it's go time
and we run you know rush into back to
base we're sitting on our platoon space
and my leading petty officer comes in
and says
hey they went and inspected the range we
didn't do a good job cleaning up
we got to go clean up our brass
so uh yeah
not exactly what i anticipated yeah
bud um it's funny yeah yeah
so you guys are doing this friday night
oh my point was that
we we would sometimes get recalled to do
something and they wouldn't tell us it
was training
until
like we were ready to launch or and we
some guys would know some guys they go
this is just training but of course i'd
be like no way man it's real you know
um but you guys so did some of you think
maybe this is just a big training
operation uh in the beginning we kind of
did but
with bull being in charge and all the
you know we saw
a lot of uh
brass around us you know this was the
first mission ever to be under the
direct control the joint chiefs of staff
we didn't know that at the time either
i mean we we knew that
there was guys in washington coming down
every once in a while and they would go
into the building and we'd think why are
they there you know but you know nobody
ever explained to us that
you know they were doing the same thing
up in washington dc
but uh
it was it was a uh
we we just
kind of kept in the dark and fed on
that's what we were and
that's the way it started and
we were just told do our job yeah and
that's what we were doing